[Applause]
this morning in our Saturday session the
artist known as fantastic Negrito has
had something of a tortured path to his
current success his career included a
few false starts and even an accident
that almost claimed his life but now
he's found his name his voice and his
sound yesterday it felt so good
but today musician Xavier de frappe alas
was 45 when he created his alter-ego
fantastic Negrito four years ago
[Music]
then last year his album the last days
of Oakland won a Grammy you basically
had your breakthrough in middle-aged
Italy
middle rage how does that feel um I love
it man because I don't want anything it
wasn't always that way the son of a
somali Caribbean immigrant deferral has
grew up in Massachusetts and on the
streets of Oakland he went by the name
Xavier when he signed a million-dollar
record contract in the 90s and released
a prince influenced solo album x-factor
[Music]
it would be the first of what he calls
his three musical lives what happened at
the end of that first life well that
first life I was at the peak of my
extreme narcissism mm-hmm I ended up in
a car accident I was at a coma three
weeks and it you know ruined my playing
hands so they said it was 1999 and he
soon lost his record deal his second
life was in the LA underground playing
afropunk in basement fans by 2007 he
stopped making music and I quit
everything I sold my pianos keyboards
guitars I had no interest why why did
you quit I felt like I had nothing else
to say and I needed a new chapter in my
life a new experience and that would be
becoming a cannabis farmer right
completely legal his third musical life
started by chance when he picked up a
guitar again to amuse his young son the
smile was so big that it I got excited
yeah I felt she was kind of going down
my spine and I got a little bit scared
too cuz I was like what what is this it
turned out to be the birth of fantastic
Negrito an artist with a new devotion to
the blues I thought this deep emotion in
connection I remember hearing skip James
voice that it felt like a blanket mm-hmm
it was something very African about it
it's very very interesting and so I was
like I want to connect to that you know
to these black roots fantastic Negrito
became a name that I could mention these
people every time I did an interview
because I thought that they are so
important can you use your hand to play
guitar well I kind of just get into
submission it's very crude yeah and it's
got a lot of feeling and I think that's
what you know the fantastic me the
musician who nearly died in 1999 now has
a new album please don't be dead
why do you think you've been able to
reinvent yourself so many times I think
it's maybe the American dream in some
weird way I always look at my journey
it's like the American Dream I think
we're kind of a people I came in we can
do